-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching at home.
Thank you for tuning in.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys, a lot of people
are talking about this.
It was just revealed that
the Pentagon deleted
all January 6th-related
text messages
from the phones of
key Trump defense officials.
Yeah. When she heard,
Hillary Clinton was like,
"Well, well, well...
Wow."
I actually think Trump
had nothing to do with this.
If he was involved, the phones
wouldn't have been wiped.
They would have been flushed.
Listen to this.
FEMA just warned that if
the software for
the National Alert System
isn't updated,
it could be hacked to send out
fake emergency alerts.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Even worse,
FEMA heard and was like,
"Oh, no, that message
didn't come from us."
Some more news from Washington.
President Biden's still
testing positive for COVID,
but his doctor said
that he's feeling good
and that his only lingering
symptom is a loose cough.
-Oh, gross!
Please don't say those words.
-Say what? Say loose cough.
-Come on, Jimmy.
I can't hear that phrase, man.
Don't say it again.
-What? What?
I'm just telling people
the news.
President Biden has...
-A loose cough.
-"Loose cough."
-A bit of a loose cough.
-Loose cough.
-A loose cough.
-Jimmy, come on, man.
Seriously.
I'm going to throw up in my hat.
-From what? From what?
From just hearing this?
-The president's doctor says
he has a loose cough.
-...but has a loose cough.
-A loose cough.
-A bit of a loose cough.
-Kind of loose cough.
-Alright, man, enough. You won.
Just talk about something else.
-Like what?
-I don't know.
Something bland,
like the weather.
-Okay, then.
-A moist feeling hanging
over the city right now.
-Sticky mugginess.
-Still hot and sticky.
-Steam, sticky, sweaty.
-Yes.
-Are you proud of yourself now?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I am a little bit, yeah.
Moving on.
Tariq Trotter, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Moist weather.
-Moist!
-He has a moist cough.
-Moist cough.
-Moving on,
I read that The White House
has sanctioned
a woman who is believed to be
Vladimir Putin's girlfriend.
-Ooh!
-It's weird when your girlfriend
breaks up with you and says,
"It's not you, it's the
international sanctions."
Some business news.
Tinder just announced that
their C.E.O. is stepping down.
Yep. She's been there less than
a year, but, ironically,
it's still the longest-ever
relationship on Tinder.
Yep, since it's Tinder,
I'm surprised it wasn't
announced and then the C.E.O.
didn't just ghost the company.
But this was nice.
On her last day,
the whole staff made her
a giant collage of
unsolicited naked selfies.
-Aww!
-That was sweet.
Well, guys,
everyone loves TikTok,
but, sometimes, you just want to
skip the boring parts
of a video and get right to
the good part.
Well, we are here to help you.
For instance, if you are
watching this video,
you can skip this part.
Yeah.
And just go right to this.
We're here to help. We...
[ Laughter ]
She tricked the dog.
-Yeah, tricked that dog.
-Really tricked that dog.
-She got that dog.
That dog's dumb.
-Yeah, that dog is dumb, right?
-That dog is dumb, man.
-Yeah.
-Can't figure out nothing.
Whack!
-Idiot of a dog.
-Did they build
their house wrong?
-Let me...
[ Laughter ]
Let me give you another example.
During this production of
"Peter Pan,"
you can skip this part.
-Yeah, yeah.
And just go right to this part.
Wow! That's an entrance.
[ Laughter ]
That's an entrance right there.
I love that.
And this one.
Oh, man,
this might be my favorite.
Here's the final example.
You can skip this part.
-Cheers.
-You won't believe it.
And you go right to this part.
-Oh! Oh!
-Wow!
-Oh! Oh-ho-ho!
Oh! Moist cough.
-Yeah, loose cough.
[ Coughs hoarsely ]
Some entertainment news.
Warner Bros. spent $90 million
on its upcoming "Batgirl" movie,
but following
poor test-audience reviews,
they decided
not to release it anywhere.
-Ooh!
-I've got to say, if this
is part of a marketing scheme,
it's working, 'cause now I
really want to see this movie.
I mean, this is rough.
I mean, there's a TV series
about Alfred the butler,
but this is where
they drew the line?
How bad could it be?
I mean, not only did
"Cats" get released,
it was in theaters
for two whole months.
Well, we asked Warner Bros.
to send over the best parts of
the movie so we could
judge for ourselves,
and this is what we got.
♪♪
There you go. Okay.
Yeah.
-Wow.
-Hey, guys, listen to this.
I read that CNN is
really struggling right now,
as their ratings have plummeted
nearly 30% since last year.
The bad news is,
CNN had to report the story.
The good news is,
nobody really saw it, you know?
So...
Apparently,
CNN is losing so much money,
they just took Wolf Blitzer
and Anderson Cooper
to a pawnshop and tried to
sell them as silver.
-What?
-Yeah.
Guys, we're always trying to
put a positive spin on the news.
So to make things
seem a little lighter,
we took some news clips and put
a Snapchat filter on them.
It's time for "Filtered News."
Check this out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ "Filtered News" ♪
-Two top aides to
former vice president Pence
have now testified before
a federal grand jury.
-In Washington, President Biden
is in isolation again
after another positive COVID
test over the weekend.
-Sources say
the Homeland Security
inspector general
first learned of
missing Secret Service texts
in May of 2021.
-The Federal Reserve is
expected to raise interest rates
for the fourth time this year.
-In Washington, a troubling
report on the U.S. economy
is raising new concerns
about a recession.
-Sox are falling apart,
but let's build for
the future of the least.
-John, that was expert work.
You turned the Mega Millions
into book promotion,
then into Red Sox promotion.
-CNN can now reveal how Russia
stopped democratic change
over 6,000 miles away in Sudan.
That's right. There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, you guys, get this.
It was just announced that
private companies
flying to the
International Space Station
will have to be chaperoned by
a former NASA astronaut.
Yep, space chaperones.
Yep, they make sure everyone
keeps their rocket
in their pocket.
Yeah. Of course, they'll have
that one fun chaperone
who's like,
"Hey, I spiked the Tang."
And finally,
it's now the middle of summer.
And, obviously, the big trend
of summer '22 is,
of course, coastal grandmas.
Everyone's talking about it.
You got grandmas in Monterey,
grandmas in the Hamptons,
Cape Cod.
I'm talking floppy hats, linen
outfits, giant sunglasses.
It is the biggest thing.
In fact, it's the hottest song
in the world right now,
and we're about to debut
the music video.
So here it is, the world
premiere of "Coastal Grandma"
with a little help
from Jane Fonda.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ You don't know what
your body's doing to me ♪
♪ It's like all your cool
comes naturally ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Tell me what you call this,
I'm in agony ♪
-Coastal grandmother.
-♪ Oh, okay ♪
♪ Oh, oh, okay ♪
♪ Statement necklace,
floppy hat ♪
♪ Breeze in your linen pants ♪
♪ Ain't nothing wrong
with that ♪
♪ Nothing wrong with that ♪
♪ Your gardening gloves,
they just drive me crazy ♪
♪ Only you could wear 18 shades
of beige and navy ♪
♪ Open-concept kitchen,
sensible shoes ♪
♪ Divorce your husband
and then binge "The View" ♪
♪ Go to the beach and put some
shells in a jar ♪
♪ Put it in the bathroom
near the towel bar ♪
♪ Near the towel bar ♪
♪ Coastal grandma ♪
♪ $5 check in the mail ♪
♪ She's fine as hell ♪
♪ Coastal grandma ♪
♪ It's plain to see ♪
♪ Got me eating dinner at 3:00 ♪
♪ Coastal grandma ♪
♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-Now, anybody need a Tums? Hmm?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-My thanks to Jane Fonda.
Her new movie, "Luck,"
will premiere on Apple TV+
this Friday.